we were talking about this yesterday
after the show I don't know how we got
on this we're talking about Baker
Mayfield and then we're like Russell
Wilson the the comps are you know with
Russell Wilson Baker Mayfield and around
five eleven six feet and then we're like
do you think that Russell Wilson can
dunk Seaton you were the only one who
said that you didn't think Russell
Wilson could dunk no offense
I just don't think and I'm sure no
offense taken Russell Wilson joining us
down the Seahawks quarterback I you 511
the debate is can you dunk
I could definitely probably dunk right
now I think
no no not definitely probably can you
don't i haven't played much basketball
lately but I can get up I can get up now
so I would say I can definitely get the
rim for sure I would probably be better
at an alley-oop than actually going up
with the ball one-handed I'm gonna need
it kind of easier I'm gonna need a video
in the offseason it wait how good were
you in high school in basketball
can you be my point guard yeah I can a
lead to your hoop but I don't like to
pass though your ball were you any good
in high school you know you know they
say about basketball players if you're
you're a great defender and a great
rebounder when you hear this comparison
Baker Mayfield plays a lot like Russell
Wilson what do you think of that well I
haven't had a chance to see him play
that much honestly you know if it's
we're always playing on Sundays and then
Saturday nights we're usually in
meetings and all but I hear he's playing
phenomenal football you know he's up to
the Heisman Trophy you know that I heard
so you know he's a great great football
player here and he's making crazy plays
so you know I hope I hope the best for
him in his career I think it's because
he makes something out of nothing and
and watching you against the Eagles in
fact watching you this entire season it
feels like you're making something out
of nothing is that true or is that just
how we're observing you know how you're
playing
well I think we got some phenomenal guys
that help me you know make some cool
plays you know Jimmy Graham has been on
fire you know anything might duck ball
one on fire Paul Richardson on fire talk
and making some crazy cool plays on fire
you know so those guys make me look good
JD mckissick and Mike Davis the other
night so you know I you know I think a
lot of it is that's part of the game you
know I think that definitely scramble
situations are always tough in the
defense but you know I think those guys
make the good good catches and I just
trust them and give them a good chance
all right but how much of that is
unscripted you know and again I probably
say 20% of it you know I would probably
say you know things just happened you
know where it's just the play happens
and you just you have no idea what's
gonna happen and that's what makes it
really tough went on the defense for
sure was that a forward lateral or just
a regular what was it a wasn't called
correct interesting on Fenton on film it
looks like it's it's backwards when we
watch it on film you know no you know I
just felt they fell backward because a
guy was behind me when I pitched it you
know and so and I keep going forward so
it's not like I just stopped and stayed
there you know and you know physics is
tough but you know the game happens so
fast you know and you know we definitely
thought it was backwards and during the
game for sure okay but if you were an
official and you got a chance for replay
how would you have called that to the
natural eye on the field it definitely
looks like it's backwards because I keep
going forward he's still behind me but I
don't know the exact rule is on that if
it's from where you where the ball
leaves your hand where the guy you know
what what that's like because I kept I
kept going forward you know what I mean
so the natural I definitely looks like
the guys behind me for sure he's Russell
Wilson Seahawks quarterback you got
Jacksonville coming up this weekend in
Jacksonville good god that's trouble
it's gonna it's gonna be it's gonna be a
tough game we're looking forward to it
though Elias Campbell I think might be
the defensive you got wagner's been
great clays Campbell's been a beast for
Jacksonville have you broken down tape
yet yeah we've been watching a bunch of
film on those guys you know ever since
you know syenite game you know early
Monday morning and all day all all day
Tuesday and this morning already and so
it's
you know it's been it's fun to watch
these guys that's not actually on the
play what did you challenge well you go
from the Eagles and that might be the
best front that you'll see all season
long
but I wanted to ask you about Carson
Wentz that people talk about him as an
MVP candidate how much are you taking in
during a game when you're watching
Carson Wentz well I really try to focus
on my place as much as I can you know
and getting to the getting to the
sidelines and you know looking you know
at the plays on the surface and all that
kind of stuff and studying as much as I
can and what's going on and and then
what happens is you know when I get a
chance to speak up and see you know on
third downs or something like that when
I get a chance to watch great players
play I love watching up so when I get to
watch a guy like Carson or or other guys
play you know for a hot minute it's
always it's always fun to watch them
make their plays who would be your MVP
right now if you got to vote and I don't
get the vote I have the power to give it
to you today Russell well for yourself
but I think Carson's been playing great
all year you know I think that obviously
Tom's been playing great too you know
those guys have been winning so you know
would I vote for myself I know I can't
vote for myself I'd never vote for
myself I don't think I think that I just
want to keep doing my job at the highest
level that I can and let the people go
good to vote you know make their
decisions I don't get a vote
but I'd vote for you right now I don't
think anybody's done more or their
offense than you have and appreciate him
a man now of course and when she was on
the line I'd probably say the same thing
to him but since it's you right now
that's why I'm saying what would you say
what would you say to Tom I think tom
has got to the point where he's like
LeBron Russell I I just think we take it
for granted that Brady is going to do
this and it's it's you know Michael
Jordan you just go yeah that's that's it
that's a normal season for him when
she's having a season we didn't expect
you're playing the way you've played in
previous years I think that's my wince
is going to be the MVP what do you think
of my logic is this is this there's a
there's been you know to watch Tom
playing at the level if he's playing
right now it's pretty cool to watch and
see Carson too as well so I mean
you know December is an important month
that's for sure give me the sport that
you hope your daughter excels in the
sport them I hope my daughter excels in
yeah um I think she I think she'd be a
great soccer player I have always loved
soccer you know world-class soccer
player miss you're gonna be fast she's
gonna be fast cuz cuz Sierra's a
tremendous athlete she's really really
fast got long legs she can run so maybe
maybe track she's maybe she'll be able
to be in can your wife beat you in a
40-yard dash no but she could be most
really could she how many how many
teammate could your wife beat in a
40-yard day oh I have no idea she
definitely got some speed that's for
sure
but your son held your son he's three
and a half all right three and a half
going and going on four is he playing
for does he have a favorite player does
he notice football is he all into it
yeah he's obsessed with loves he loves
watching he loves playing the house
every night he's always on the Seahawks
you know he's always gets pumped you
know how long he's always ready to play
so yeah it's always fun and he loves
going to games and screaming his lungs
out so he's pretty fun the games that's
for sure
tell us what you're doing with
Microsoft's create Change Program oh man
it's been amazing um you know a lot of a
lot of people don't get to see what NFL
players do you know off the field and
everything else yeah everybody gets to
see us on the field and everything but
you know it's been pretty awesome being
a partner with Microsoft and as you know
I'm a fortunate situation to go to
Seattle Children's every Tuesday and
it's been an amazing partner to
Microsoft because we're doing this in a
program create change and and the cool
part is with the Microsoft Surface we've
been we've been at the forefront of
change and it's been amazing because
what's happening is these these patients
that are in the Seattle Children's
Hospital you know it's always tough as a
family every room you go into it's
always different as you know and and
every room we go into is different and
every situation is different but you
know the cool part about Microsoft and
what we're doing is we're keeping it
where we can have that constant
communication between the patients and
the doctors and the nurses and everybody
else at all times and that's what it's
been really really fun and I'm honored
to be a part of this
why not you Foundation and and Microsoft
and Seattle Children's and and it's been
a really really cool thing just to see
these relationships between the kids you
know at sale children's and and and the
doctors and everybody else and that way
they can have that open line of
communication and continue to focus on
their treatment and everything else but
also focus on their joy and I mean
living a joyful life and and you know
the whole reason why we formed the one
that you foundation my daddy's always
asked me you know Russ why not you you
know why not you be a Super Bowl winning
quarterback why not you graduate in
three years why not you why not you why
don't you play professional baseball and
that's the fundamental question that we
all have to ask ourselves is why not you
no matter if you're a church group no
matter if you are a football team like
Michelle Seahawks or if you're if you're
a person that's trying to be successful
in in the arts and in trying to do be an
actor or actress or if you're a person
who's you know trying to overcome cancer
the reality is is that we have to ask
ourselves a fundamental question I think
encourage our own selves and well you
know why not you wanted us and so it's
been an amazing thing that we're doing
and I'm grateful to obviously be with
Microsoft as a partner with them on this
idea of create change now it's great
surface dot-com / NFL to check out
Russell's video and how you can win two
tickets to Super Bowl 50 to Russ I'll
leave you with this go lux the man I'll
see you soon thank you alright but for
more Dan Patrick show to the audience
Channel 239 on DirecTV or download the
Dan Patrick show at
[Music]